the weekend is making his triumphant
return with a brand new album arriving
this friday titled dawn fm which of
course is the follow-up to his 2020
project after hours yes and i know you
and i both can't wait for this it
features a star-studded list of
collaborators like tyler the creator lil
wayne quincy jones and jim carrey yeah
you heard that take a look at the teaser
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you are now listening to 103.5 don fm
you've been in the dark for way too long
it's time to walk into the light and
accept your fate with open arms
[Music]
yeah i like that drop i like when i drop
it we should have got your reaction we
should have got your blind reaction to
her because you should have seen her she
was like i was like this is amazing when
i first saw the trail and then i was
like so i was wait i knew jim carrey was
a part of it and i was like wait where's
jim carrey yeah i heard his voice so
cool so so here it is collaborative jim
carrey gave all the praise to the new
album writing on twitter i listened to
don fm with my good friend abel the
weekend last night it was deep and
elegant and it danced me around the room
that's really nice to say i'm thrilled
to play a part in his symphony and it
was all fate for the weekend who wrote
back thank you for being a part of this
it's kismet full circle i need to know
the story on this i like their
friendship story the two of them are
homies they've been hanging out i didn't
know this i i like when you think about
two people who
i don't know
essentially like toronto natives yeah
that makes sense yeah meeting up
together and like uh the weekend being a
fan of jim carrey's from way back when
he was young like i imagine that's what
that comment is about things coming
coming full circle then getting to work
together and him getting praise from
someone who he looked at as as an idol
i'm sure someone's a big fan of that's
super cool yeah martavius is saying this
is a great start to 2022. can't wait
for new weekend hot spicy tea saying i'm
excited cannot wait really excited for
this because the weekend doesn't just
drop an album and that's it he makes it
like a whole performance element i mean
when i was just asking before with that
last album i mean he changed he was
wearing bandages and he continues the
theme you know and takes it into his
life and appearances and red carpets so
i can't wait to see what he's gonna do
with this
and i mean he is one of the biggest
artists in the world oh yeah and his his
music has been
it's almost like
um
we haven't stopped listening to the
weekend yet i agreed that it didn't feel
like there was a pause it didn't feel
like there was a pause and then here
comes a new album which is a great thing
for 2020. i'm excited yeah i'm so so
excited for this and just so proud of
him because he can be like he's toronto
as opposed
sorry it's not funny